Thank you all people from Dawlish for helping
us and thank you for all people of England
that hosted Ukrainians
I just want to say thank you to my host family
in Dawlish for all the tremendous help and
support they provided me during this year. That empowered me to be better and braver.
Thank you one more time to everyone who supports
Ukraine.
I'd like to say big thank you to my host family
and I really appreciate your support during
such difficult times for me and for all Ukrainians.
When I was in despair you were trying to distract
me and show the positive side of my life and
I'll always remember our fascinating trips
to Longleat, Dartmoor and the ones like cooking,
[INDISTINGUISHABLE] , and watching movies together.
As I said it was fun and such a great cultural
exchange in my life.
I guess during these times you became as the
second family for me because you're always
worried about me, literally I've never met
such kind and generous people in my life.
I want to say thank you so much.
I'm so grateful to my host family who gave
us not only home and the family as well.
Rosie is like a sister and her family became
native to us.
Thanks everyone for supporting Ukraine.
Dear host I would like to say thank you to
each of you for this opportunity you have
given to Ukrainian families.
For the fact that the majority of those currently
in Britain have support and feel safe.
For the fact that we have the opportunity
to continue to work and enjoy peaceful life.
[Music] We're very grateful to you for your
kindness and support.
You have opened not only doors of your house
but also your heart.
[text appears with photo of Ukrainian girl]
With great gratitude for giving us a peaceful
sky above our heads, the opportunity to get
to know your country and much more!
Thank you!
Dear Erica and John I want to thank you so
much for all that you have done and do for
our family.
Thank you for sharing and sheltering you from
the war.
Thank you for the house, uh thank you for
the security, thank you for the silence which
is not possible in Ukraine.
My children are happy and smiling which is
the most important thing for me.
Dear John and Erica thank you for saving me
from the war and giving me a house where I
live in comfort and safety and do not hear
the sound of bombs and sirens.
Thank you for everything
Dear Erica and John thank you for the help and save me from the war, and help me.
I'm very glad that we met.
text which reads: on 9th June we celebrated
our 'second birthday', our one year anniversary
in England.
We lost Ukrainian family, but found an English
one.
Every single day we thank God for our hosting
family as they are truly amazing, kind-hearted,
very generous, supportive, loving, caring,
genuine and wonderful people, who saved our
lives, helped us to stand on our own feet
and gave us hope for a better future.
We live like one big family.
We introduced our Ukrainian cuisine to our
English family and they liked our dishes a
lot.
We happily share Ukrainian and English recipes,
trying something new and healthy at the same
time.
Thank you for the help and care, your support
is very important to us.
Thank you for all this help that you give
us.
We are very proud for this fact that you drop
to welcome complete strangers from another
country into your home.
You didn't just open the doors to your home;
you had opened the possibility for my family
to see the sky where there aren't... doesn't
feel without explosions in area.
xxx Thank you, many thank you
Thank you
Thank you we love you
We would like to sincerely thanks to our host
family who supported us throughout all the
time we stay here.
We would like to say thank you for shared
with us not just a house, food and time, but
love patience, exception and compassion.
We also would like to say thank you to all
volunteers, workers of different institutions,
teachers, everybody who is kind to us and
who help us every day.
Thank you to all of the amazing Dawlish community
- you are incredible people!
You give us strength, determination, courage
and hope for a better future.
Thank you.
Thank you from all of us.
[text]"I'm very grateful to our host family,
they are wonderful people with big hearts."
"Our hosts are very sensitive people, their
support inspires me, even now, when I have
not been home for a year.
I try to move on and build a future with their
help."
"We feel safe here and not forgotten"
"I'm glad I made the decision to take the
baby to a safe place.
Her smile and happy eyes are more important
than anything in the world.")
[text] (message to host families) You have opened
your hearts and homes, having a huge impact
on many people.
We celebrate you, your families and all who
have offered support to our guests from Ukraine.
Ends